all right livestream
starting
well looks like it's live I got a
notification on my phone which means yep
we are live it works okay so I need to
get a link copy URL paste tweet what's
up guys we clearly have a lot to talk
about but like we can talk about
whatever it's cool it's just a title no
big deal what's up hey hello hi bro hi
hi hello volume is too low
should I bring us closer let me know how
I sound let me know how I sound
cuz I see video looks pretty ok gonna
get a sound check what you guys think
volume up increase the volume please
speak loud should i boost it a little
bit this this mic volume I can turn up
right here did that get louder
yeah the chat is flying
how does this house now is it louder
than I I turned up yeah I turned it up
about 25% still low really loud let me
hear it on the oh that's great that's
there it is yeah there you go
alright see this mic it's good it's got
a little volume volume knob that's why I
linked it below it's cuz it's good
alright this one this live stream is
titled phone updates
hence the phones and plus a little
giveaway updates so I guess natural
place to start would be the giveaway
stuff cuz that was that was pretty
recent
so the giveaway is pretty awesome there
is obviously plenty of people commenting
on oh god that's a lot of phones why
would you give all those away and it's
because I wanted like I said to give as
many prizes away as possible there is a
pretty hilarious reddit post actually
about actually I'm gonna see if I can
find it again about like here's why I
think this giveaways fake which is why I
have these boxes here um first of all
it's not fake fYI I would never do that
I found it I'm not gonna link to it but
all like reads some of it which is
pretty they okay so they're super
analysing and video obviously there's a
lot of boxes in the video none of them
have shrink-wrap on them that's because
as I mentioned dbrand
skinned every single one of those phones
so they took the shrink-wrap off open
the box take the phone out skinned it
put it back put the thing back together
close it that's why there's no shrink
wrap on the boxes and yes every single
one of those boxes did have a phone in
it which is why I had all the boxes he
mentions the boxes sound hollow as if
there's no phone inside
I don't really know how to quantify that
but all the boxes have phones in them
and we took them all out and I actually
I have a picture if you want to switch
to this camera I have a picture of some
of when we were shooting all of the 25
phones I don't know if that's glared
well if it's even visible but yeah
there's there's 25 phones all equally
numbered red and black so that's a thing
that happened and I'll share more of
those photos probably later on Twitter
but the other funny thing is they're
talking about what do you say oh the I
am me that I am the I stickers which if
you've seen on the bottom of these these
boxes is always on the bottom here like
that but the way this Note 8 does they
were talking about the note eighths the
way the note eight boxes it has this
sleeve on it so they were curious about
why all the boxes looked blank it's
because we hid all of the imei stickers
because we didn't want everyone to steal
that information or getting in the heads
of the people who end up winning these
things you don't want to give out these
public IMEI numbers so we oriented all
the boxes so that they were all blank
you can do that by just taking the
sleeve off and switching it around and
putting the IMEI wherever you want so we
made them all blank on the top just by
switching them and that was that I think
that's a brick that's about it people
are also freaking out about the fact
that that much money was spent upon on
phones for a giveaway that's just how we
do that's just the way it is out here so
that's pretty much it for that but what
I really want to say for the giveaway is
this is a Twitter and Instagram giveaway
so what we were talking about is there's
gonna be people who try to scam you into
thinking you've won it's gonna happen
and because this is you know it's a it's
a randomization from Twitter and
Instagram D brand has their they're
handling the entire logistics process
essentially so randomizing the
cross-section of followers on each
social network and actually shipping
them out and handling all the import
fees wherever you live all that stuff so
they have all the phones right now for
that but people it's also really
easy to just try to mass message that
group of people
let me just message everyone who follows
Marquez and dbrand
saying I'm Marquez and asking for their
shipping in their bank information for
import fees it's not happening like that
first of all December 25th is the day
all the winners get picked so if someone
messages you claiming to be me or
claiming to be D brand sometime between
now and December 25th clearly it's not
but then on that day of that's when
you'll see all the winners get picked
it's a just literally a random
cross-section generated by code and
that's that's how it happens yeah that
is a red one plus 5p we'll get to these
is there's a whole bunch of a updates
again for the whole title stream but
that's that's the giveaway update
there's anything I missed there they
just haters you did this last year that
is true if you are curious about
giveaways I've ever done I don't do them
very often but last year I gave away a
hundred one plus three tees and pretty
much the same format cross section of
social posts and whoever's following the
two accounts is entered to win same idea
they all got those phones they all were
given proof on social it was awesome
actually giving away that many phones so
yeah where is the smartphone Awards 2017
so Nast that's a december thing so that
will happen right around the end of the
year when I'm pretty sure all the phones
have come out you've probably noticed
one of these phones on a desk is not
like the others this one you guys did a
tweet about this one there's a sad story
this I mentioned in the review it's
actually sharp at this point it's
literally it's not the slipperiest phone
ever but it's a slippery si phone ever
it's got these rounded sides and it's
definitely you can tell this was my
daily driver I use this one everyday um
it slid off a counter or not a counter
like a dresser and I left the room for
like 10 minutes so this is what happens
yesterday
I had my phone up on this counter it was
like face down like that just like a
normal surface like this I think it was
like plastic left the room and a couple
minutes later I'm in the other room and
I hear like this thud and I was like
what was that sound and I literally left
the room and I went downstairs because I
thought the sound came from downstairs
like in the kitchen I'm looking around
like what fell did a salt shaker fall
like what is the deal I couldn't find it
went back upstairs one in the other room
that I left the phone in and I find this
phone on the ground that clearly
committed suicide and people were saying
put a skin over it which actually
sometimes works but in this case because
the glass is so wrecked it's a little
depressed on this side and it's kind of
sharp right here and not even a skin can
save that one so yeah that one's over
ice I'd put my sim in another iPhone
because I actually have another iPhone
which is pretty awesome but this would
normally cost $550 at an Apple store to
fix it's the most expensive iPhone to
fix ever obviously that's a lot and it's
the most expensive iPhone ever this one
I think it's just gonna remain like this
in posterity there's chunks of glass
missing from around the camera it's bad
all right I'll put it away I don't you
guys don't want to see that there now
it's now there's a clean iPhone on this
table hey Mark is the question is I had
are you how are you going to weed out
inactive accounts and body counts that
is a challenge and ideally none of those
accounts win but that's gonna be up to
dbrand to like truly randomized as a
process and pick the winners are the
phones of the highest capacity
I don't think so this particular one I
think all the iPhones will be the $9.99
base model so what does that 64 gigs or
yeah 64 gigs and all the notes are the
64 gig as well I think what is this I'm
pretty sure the base for both is 64 gigs
so that's what's up
hi hello hi did it fall how did it fall
anyway it just slid I say maybe it got a
notification and like
my phone like buzzed and like slid off
the table but I couldn't I can't confirm
because I didn't put it near the edge I
would never do that that means it slid
gradually over the course of like
several minutes while I was in another
room until it fell which is that's
pretty rough
yup
all right so this is the Android daily
driver I think that's the other thing
people were asking about I usually carry
two phones that's something that's been
a case for at least like two years now I
usually carry one Android phone and I
carry one iPhone so for a while ago for
me that was Galaxy Note 8 and iPhone 7
plus and then iPhone 8 came out and I
switched to iPhone 8 so the Android
rotation is much faster cuz I'm testing
a bunch of different phones lately it
was the razor phone that's this guy the
suite hundred twenty Hertz display the
massive amazing front-facing speakers
and it's a it's kind of a rock in terms
of build quality but long story short
like I said mentioned in the full review
the camera is so bad that it's an actual
deal-breaker for me and I had to switch
back to the pixel because the camera is
that good and the thing is I think Danny
I think Danny tweeted this sort of Danny
wins yet super-scientific tweeted this
recently but it's something I think the
same about which is camera comparisons
for a while are not really ruined but
will be a little less interesting
because the pixel tube crushes
everything in the camera department and
it's not that close like iPhone 10 has a
pretty great camera and then pixel 2 is
still clearly better it's like when you
have a clear 1/2 in the world in a sport
it's crazy I don't know anyway so that's
that's razor phone but that's what I've
switched to so my daily right now is the
iPhone 10 256 silver and the pixel 2:128
panda I know some of you call this the
penguin it's not it's a panda although I
get why you call it the penguin I'm just
saying it's a little late to switch
what's good let me look at these chat
the chat is oh my god that shadows fly
oh wow that would explain why it's
flying what is good what's good all
right here's another fun we can move on
to one plus 5t this is a ok so again
these are all phones and this is in the
description besides these two these are
all phones that i haven't reviewed yet
one plus 5t I did a top five features on
and I really like this phone a lot it's
a well-built it's kind of like a blade
they didn't make the battery any bigger
so it's still a pretty thin phone and
it's got this red D brand skin on it so
it looks pretty slick right now but this
is a really good phone for under 500
bucks it's 479 I want to say the killer
feature of this phone and I want to
stress the difference between this in
the iPhone 10 the killer feature on this
phone turns out to be that face unlock
which I don't know if I can demonstrate
it here it's kind of hard to see I don't
know if you can you see that is that on
the skin right now if I turn this off
pointed towards me it's hard to point it
towards me and unlock it it's the
fastest face unlock I've ever used on a
phone which has a lot of people talking
about like well this is way better than
face ID it's that much faster here's the
thing those are two very different
although they seem the same very
different technologies so here's the
difference
face ID on the iPhone 10 is an entire
replacement to touch ID it is a secure
thing it does your phone unlocked but it
also does your bank transactions your
Apple ID your purchasing of apps
everything it uses the true depth sensor
it uses the front facing information
bounces all these lasers off your face
or is it it's uh it's infrared so I
don't know if I can call it lasers
bounces all the infrared dots off your
face creates a depth map recognizes you
in multiple scenarios if you grow a
mustache or your face ages slightly it
recognizes you because of a learning
algorithm all this stuff face ID is
really smart so that's why it does all
those things but it also takes a second
you take your phone in your pocket and
then it unlocks like it's a second to
actually get into your phone where
everyone looks at now this new face
front-facing camera on the oneplus looks
at you instantly unlocks seems like it
must be better right seems like it must
be better but it's not it only uses the
front-facing camera face idea isn't use
the front-facing camera at all it uses
all the invisible sensors that you don't
see this uses only the front-facing
camera meaning it's susceptible to
potentially some of the same security
risks that would come from not getting
that extra information number one
doesn't use as much most much depth
information I couldn't fool it with a
photo I actually printed a photo of
myself and tried to unlock it and like
may give some depth and everything that
didn't work but oneplus already
acknowledges I think internally that
it's not quite to the same level of
security so they have a finger parameter
on the back still first of all so they
kept that so keep using that for the
more secure things that's what it's good
for but it also won't work in low light
it won't work if you're super backlit
these are all things that you can shine
infrared light on yourself with and true
in face ID and it'll still work this
won't work at night face ID facial
recognition won't work at night it's
using a low-light camera it won't work
when you're backlit because these
cameras struggle in your backlit so
certain things like that separate these
two experiences and what they're good at
overall though 1 + 5 t is turned out to
be pretty freakin sweet for this amount
of money what other questions you guys
have about this 1 + 5 t or any of the
stuff on the desk so when I was giveaway
question if I don't use my if I don't
use my Twitter and Instagram will my I
can't be considered a bot and
disqualified no as long as you're
following the rules which there are only
to follow both the counseling a win
Steve Jobs dropped that iPhone what
which phone here has the longest battery
life during regular operation I would
give that award to razor phone which
right now is edging out pixel to an
iPhone 10 probably pixel - in second
place
iPhone 10 and third place iPhone 10
battery life isn't quite as good as
iPhone 8 + which has that smaller screen
and bigger cell so I'd put that a little
bit below of pixel but right now your
best battery life that is actually the
razor phone what's up what product you
looking forward to most camera or phones
or other cool tech honestly I have to
say a Tesla Roadster which is probably
not the most common answer but I have to
say it and looking forward to that tech
electric motors massive batteries and
cars so fam marques thanks for all you
do
thanks for watching I hope one day my
channel will be even half this size this
is what I love to do thanks for
inspiring again thanks for watching and
I'm I'm glad to be in a position where
the videos I make get seen by people who
are also encouraged to make videos
themselves
is it worth upgrading from pixel excel
to pixel to excel I've been having a few
minor issues and it's very tempting so
if you have been having issues it seems
like you're looking for an upgrade in
which case I'd say yeah this is a great
phone to upgrade to but a lot of people
are are considering either they have
like an even older phone and they're
considering do I buy pixel to excel or
pixel XL right now both of them are new
in which case you could probably save
your money and still get a great phone
with future off software updates and a
great camera and great performance in
stock Android in the pixel XL the og but
if you're having issues you will not be
disappointed in this phone pretty sure
I'd be curious what issues you have with
the pixel though how's the battery of
the 5 T compared to the 5 it's been
alright I mean it's not notably better
or worse people have been complaining
about the fact the battery is not bigger
even though it's a bigger phone and a
bigger screen and that's because they
didn't make the phone any thicker so
it's still I think of 3,000 million
power cell
but it's a pretty good battery life
still no complaints from me have you
updated the pixel to the latest beta and
have you noticed a visual difference
oh man that has been fun okay yeah I do
want to show you guys this I didn't even
put this in the notes but okay the pixel
got an update you know how there was all
the complaints about the display of the
pixel - it's almost funny to me how
massive of a change they made of like
all the colors look muted it looks
really dull srgb doesn't really pop for
me and this AMOLED display has so much
more range why don't you guys use it so
they pushed an update to make the
saturated mode a little bit more crazy I
wonder if I can show this alright here's
my home screen right now
am i off with the glare is this good
like that so that's the way I hope this
comes through in the live stream it
might not but that's the way the phone
looks in the boosted mode now if I go
into our display settings here so I'm
making a lot of noise you have your
colors this is the boosted mode and in a
normal mode again I go home this is the
the original srgb everyone's complaining
about you know it's still pretty dull
not too bad but boosted is what I've
been using and people are complaining
this doesn't really change much it's not
really boosted enough I want that I want
that Samsung full saturated look so what
they did with the software update was
they added this saturated mode and when
you click it everything gets blasted in
saturation
oh man it's really hard to to show the
colors here but like it's gone to the
next level of like over saturation I
almost think they like wanted to make
people regret asking for it because it's
so much more saturated in this mode than
it is in natural or boosted so that's
what I want to show you but it's I'll
just leave it on boost it it looks lit
religious - saturated
you put it in a that saturated mode so I
just leave it and boost it it's crazy
though why no pixel 2xl giveaway oh
that's because this phone is even harder
to get the henna iPhone 10 trying to get
25 pixel to excels that'll be pretty
tough and also because the fact that I
kind of want it to be that thousand
dollar phone giveaway where iPhone 10 is
a thousand dollars do you want to buy it
maybe maybe not but if it's free I'll do
it and then androids version of that
pixel too isn't a thousand dollars but
Note 8 is so that's the same thing on
Android side thousand dollars do I
really want to spend that much maybe not
but if you win it it's great so that's
why we went with note over pixel
obviously I'm sure people would be happy
getting a free one either way what are
your thoughts about a 5 inch screen with
no bezels for a smaller phone I have a
large hand but I find the iPhone 10 and
s 8 or too tall yeah that'd be nice I
actually so iPhone 10 is a 5.8 inch
display I would actually want a and
that's corner-to-corner I believe when
you measure it even though it's a little
bit narrower I would want a bigger
iPhone 10 display I think I would be
cool with like a 6.2 inch iPhone 10 so
that would be like an iPhone 10 plus and
we've seen these rumours of it start to
pop up now it's never too early for
iPhone rumors but this is that 5.8 inch
corner to corner and I think a 5 inch
corner to corner like a smaller version
like that would also be pretty nice the
thing is Apple never really makes three
of the same form factor iPhone it's
always one or two so I don't think
that's gonna happen but I'm interested
to see how they handle it next year how
does the second camera on the five t
work
what is intelligent pixel technology
that is a great question I don't know I
would love to find out that Chad is
flying but that's my ok so here's here's
the way they describe it to me and all
of their logic makes sense except for
the fact that I don't know how they do
it their logic with the dual cameras on
the back of this phone is you know we
don't need a telephoto cam
to do portrait mode we can do it with AI
which okay great other phones are doing
that too they still have portrait mode
that's cool
so what is the second camera for the
second camera is a special low-light
camera it has an F 1.7 aperture
okay well the primary camera also has an
F 1.7 aperture so that's a little
confusing why is this second camera
better at low-light besides that it
isn't optically stabilized as far as I
know so it's the same aperture different
sensors are sorry yes same aperture
different sensor both no I know oh is
what's better about it they call it
intelligent pixel technology and here's
what they say it does is it combines and
it's also a higher megapixel count
it's a twenty-something megapixel camera
21 versus a small and megapixel count so
that pixels are smaller worse for
low-light this technology combines four
pixels into one don't know what that
means physically speaking but that gives
you a four times larger pixel for better
low-light performance and better high
ISO sensitivity that's intelligent pixel
technology and that's why it'll take
that sensor in the lowest of low light
scenarios here's the thing when I think
about physics and like the physical
sensors and what they do a pixel is a
pixel no matter what if you take this 21
megapixel sensor and spread it out over
this this area each physical pixel is a
certain size and you don't just dissolve
the border between pixels to make bigger
ones like I'm not sure what they mean by
combines four pixels into one so that's
my challenge with understanding that and
the fact that it doesn't work that well
leads me to believe it's not doing the
sort of magic it implies it does it's
pretty ok sometimes but oftentimes the
main camera does just as well if not
better in low light so they probably
could have just gone with one camera
like the pixel two and and just focus
that focus on that entirely that's just
me though
haha I haven't use any Android till now
is it worth upgrading the iPhone 8 if
yes 8 or 8 + oh you've only used Android
oh yeah if you watch my iPhone 8 review
that's a pretty good phone - iPhone 8
and 8 plus are great I prefer big phones
what about these other phones on the
table since we kind of have them there I
might as well steamroll through these
real quick so if your stream is lagging
refresh the browser like if stuff is
getting choppy or if your internet
connections being weird or stuff's
dropping off or if you didn't get that
audio update just refresh it once it'll
probably all be good alright the rest of
these phones right okay so I have pixel
- this is the daily iPhone 10 as a daily
that's the thing we have 1 + 5 T which I
talked about we have this phone here
this is a kind of an oddball this is
blackberry motion this is a not your
typical phone is this in the matte frame
right there not your typical form
because blackberry usually puts
keyboards on their phones they didn't
put one on this phone geez you didn't
put one on this phone they just put a
full touch screen and the virtual
keyboard which looks like that or if you
don't want to put it in the browser no
thanks
virtual keyboard looks like that that's
the black gray keyboard it's kind of a
weird thing because blackberry are used
to you know you people buy BlackBerry's
to get either the keyboard or the
business apps and everything blackberry
does well it still has that still has
blackberry hub in there it still has all
these blackberry features that you saw
on the Prive and previous BlackBerry's
but it's all touchscreen now and I
haven't really even gotten oh it has an
activity button I've gotten the chance
to use this full time but I'm just kind
of observing it for now what it does
well it kind of stands up flat by itself
so that's a good plus it's always good
when a phone does that case in point oh
god now that the pressure is mounting I
have to be able to do this
okay maybe not but flat-bottomed USBC
speaker headphone jack big deal for some
people there's a headphone jack the
buttons are pretty solid clicky it's
it's a lot of metal to be honest and the
carbon fiber isn't actually carbon fiber
it's this coated plastic material but it
looks pretty cool so it's a blackberry
again the fingerprint reader here is
underneath this like logoed button and
you have those those big buttons on the
bottom yeah man it's it's still got big
bezels can you see that still got big
bezels top bezel bottom bezels pretty
big so I'm not convinced this is going
to save blackberry I feel like I've said
that sentence maybe 12 times in videos
but this is this is a thing that exists
now blackberry motion
good luck blackberry okay do G mix to
literally just got this haven't even
booted it up yet but remember the
original do G mix I made a video about
in the smartphone's vs. no 2017 versus
bezels video with smartphones dang that
was some weird span you guys are just
blasting emojis don't do that don't be
that guy
this is the sequel to it I guess it says
do G on the bottom again it has dual
cameras and this orientation now it has
a fingerprint reader on the back in the
middle which is the right place
good job there and put a lot of other
weird this is a heavy phone and I
believe it's ceramic which is why it
feels like this it's a big heavy build
has metal all the way around it has a
premium look now so instead of what
about red hydrogen damn I don't know man
that's you guys were asking about red
hydrogen like weeks ago like do you have
any updates to that I don't know I all I
got from red was what they told me when
I made that video and that video that I
made about the red hydrogen has
everything I'm allowed to say about it
so I don't have any updates
nothing news coming from them but to
people like me have put down money for
it
can't be about that time so looking out
for that but yeah no that's that's
definitely something what if that comes
out right around the smartphone Awards
that could be a weird one we'll see
we'll keep that updated that's the do G
mix oh I haven't even really used it yet
it's just like here's your first look
bezels are a little bigger actually it
goes back to the traditional top bottom
bezels looks like it has an extra sensor
that I've I should really boot it up and
use it but there it is
mkbhd seems electric cars will be the
first to experience solid-state
batteries when do you expect to see SSDs
in OSS bees and cell phones and other
smaller tech solid-state batteries and
cell phones I don't know exactly what
that means yet so I'm gonna have to look
that up is it in electric cars already
because I don't think that's any
different from the way it already is
electric cars use these lithium-ion
batteries we already see out there
Panasonic's been making them for years
so I don't know how long we'll see it in
cars or in phones with all this tech in
your life do you feel like you need
digital detox if you mean unplugging
then sometimes yes I just do unplug like
on a weekend for Ultimate Frisbee or
whatever I'm doing but highly
recommended okay
this last phone then I'm just gonna
blaze through a quick because it's kind
of neat is what's called what is it here
the box is pretty sweet and it's maybe
one of the coolest boxes of any phone
this year I wish I did an unboxing but
look look at this look at how about that
unboxing experience it all just kind of
unfolds
this is meizu pro 7 plus this is what
the actual phone looks like and the one
thing you may notice about it that's
kind of weird is it has a screen on the
back it has a two inch color screen on
the back of the phone and it works by
cycling between these various displays
now it's still a full on screen and
phone on the front which has this
impressing impressionable home button
right now you unlock it by swiping up
you go to multitasking just like an
iPhone by swiping up there you go it's
definitely got a heavy skin on it so if
you're not into the skins this is not
gonna make you happy but this is a meizu
phone so you kind of know we're getting
into but the thing about it is people
been talking about that screen on the
back you have the settings for it right
here secondary display you can set a
different wallpaper for the secondary
display right now it's the camera you go
back and you can decide to show
pedometer whether maybe it's kind of
motivating to see how many steps you've
taken every time you look around at the
back of the phone I just wish it was
more consistent with activating bam bam
bam bam bam bam bam bam there it is
your weather if I had taken five hundred
steps today it would show me every time
there so that's kind of neat I guess
it's not a life changer it's not gonna
make me want to never use the phone
without this again but it's maybe kind
of cool
so says why didn't you do a v3 review
it's a good phone that's a great
question because we've had so many other
reviews and so many other things we've
done in the last couple of weeks and
months that by the time like it would be
around now that I'm getting to reviewing
the v30 it's almost like too late I did
the top features video of it and none of
that's different so that's kind of why
I'm talking about it now whereas might
be thirty it's still charging over there
I meant to have it here but um okay do
you think galaxy s 9 will be launched
soon keep up the good work
Thanks no I think galaxy s 9 is gonna be
April that tends to be one that comes
out there we go V 30 so here's your V 30
this would be the most expensive phone
that's not a flagship over here so it's
not the pixel it's not the iPhone but it
is more expensive than all of these it's
about an $800 phone right now yeah it's
still a great phone it's still great
phone V 30 in case you're wondering has
the dual cameras has a super wide angle
camera on the back instead of the
telephoto but this might be the most
impressive video camera in a phone well
obviously of this year so likely ever
has all the manual controls it has an S
log modes so LG has great camera tech
and now they're using it to capture
extra dynamic range and extra
information if you're a video person
this might be one of the best phones to
get to fill around with that obviously
most people when they record video they
just go straight to auto mode and then
just hit the record button and go but if
you're not that guy then this is a
really interesting look so the 30 is
quite unique has a headphone jack there
you go right up top note 8 iPhone 10th
yes that's a thing which of these phones
will survive the long run PS I got the
one plus 5 that's always the golden
question I tend to give my nod to the
flagships as far as surviving I've used
oneplus phones also for multiple years
so I would give it a nod to one plus
five for probably surviving the long run
one plus 5t will probably also survive
LGB 30 people have had the weirdest
issue I've ever seen with LG phones is
their boot looping which has happened as
recently as did g5 I've seen but I think
LG is pretty much certified pixel to and
iPhone 10 definitely gonna last the long
run Apple tends to update their phones
for the longest that of anyone and pixel
being in line for I think two three four
years of updates is probably also gonna
survive the long run so I give the nod
to probably these two first for
surviving the longest these two on the
second tier for surviving the longest
and then blackberry who knows do G the
question mark and then meizu has their
own rom so raise your phone that's also
a toss-up does razor even make another
phone next year we're getting a razor
phone too who knows
hopefully I want to see it I want to see
120 Hertz OLED that's what I want to see
do you have a problem with edge lighting
not working while the screen is off on
the note 8 no it's usually been fine for
me it's pretty good for the alarm clock
actually because I have the alarm clock
set on my note 8 it would be set to like
gradually increase volume and so it
would start off the volume really low
and then the edge lighting would kind of
light up the table that it's on it's
pretty soothing to be honest
we're learning a lot about our a 6300
and livestreaming
turns out a 6300 sometimes overheats
when it's in a live stream for too long
when it's on and the sensor is cooking
so that's why we're talking to this
angle for a little bit can we expect
holy smokes that is exactly what I am
working on can I confirm it someone said
can we expect a portrait mode explained
video that's the exact title of the
video but I'm working on so yeah
sure you can you can expect that yeah I
deal with that all the time oh yeah
that's pretty much the gamut of what I
wanted to talk through as far as this
live stream goes anyone else have any
questions people are talking to the
super chat but not really a asking
questions so there's plenty of fast
moving giveaway update please I gave you
the giveaway update at the beginning so
if you want to scroll back to that feel
free to look at that audio is behind a
bit that may happen if again if any lag
happens you can just refresh and OH
audio is out of sync now all right maybe
that's queue to end it that makes sense
so when it comes back to this one we're
good got it
but ya know that's pretty much all I had
to say for the live stream so you got
your giveaway update you got your
smartphone updates talk through a bunch
of stuff any questions you may have this
is definitely the time to ask we can
answer a couple like a fast fast-moving
what'd he call it speed round or
whatever lightning round
lightning questions Bitcoin oh man
Bitcoin Bitcoin see I took a class I've
taken classes in college or we talked
about Bitcoin and this was years ago
and we were shocked years ago at how
fast and how consistent it was moving
and this is like I'm now two years out
of college and Bitcoin just yesterday
passed ten thousand dollars for one unit
for one Bitcoin and then this morning
passed 11,000 in that time I signed up
for coinbase
and bought
my first Bitcoin so I I'm in at around
$11,000 for a Bitcoin I don't want to
put a ton into it I think it'll be
interesting to see if it keeps going if
it starts to become theirs they could
okay but for the reason it's so hyped in
the US at least right now is because
you're starting to be able to pay for
things with Bitcoin a little bit more it
trickles a little bit more down payments
for cars and Bitcoin down payments for
major purchases in Bitcoin large
electronics expenses using Bitcoin to
pay for it and because one Bitcoin is
eleven thousand dollars you often pay
for something in like zero point zero
seven seven four eight one two three
Bitcoin and that's cool you can do that
but then Bitcoin is also convertible
back and forth between cash between US
dollars and it's pretty liquid so in a
short matter of time you can buy ten
thousand dollars in Bitcoin wait for it
to go up to twelve thousand dollars sell
it and then use that money to go do
whatever so that's what a lot of people
are doing are just buying Bitcoin over
and over again and a price as people
keep buying it just keeps going up as
the demand keeps going up price keeps
going up and it just keeps rising so let
me check what it is right now I just
installed coinbase this morning when I
want to go do that how much is a Bitcoin
let me refresh Bitcoin eleven thousand
eighty dollars it's up 1145 dollars
which is twelve percent today so long
story short really interesting again I
haven't been investing in Bitcoin at all
I just got in obviously it's not the
ideal point to invest in Bitcoin but I'm
just kind of curious so this will give
me a reason to keep track of it a little
more but yeah that is a that is a weird
one anyway
okay that's been it for this livestream
shout out to the twenty thousand of you
still watching I think that's pretty
awesome I'm gonna leave this stream up
probably too for people to catch up on
all these updates and to know about the
giveaway but that's pretty much it
we're gonna cut it if you have any
questions about the live stream
equipment we use I'll link that below
any of the video I talked about a link
that below the giveaways below that's
been it thank you for watching talk to
you guys the next one pace